استولى المتمردون الحوثيون على سفينة شحن في
البحر الأحمر بعد ظهر الأحد بعد ساعات فقط من
تحذير الجناح العسكري للجماعات الإيرانية الخلفية من أنهم
سيستهدفون
أي سفينة ترفع العلم الإسرائيلي أو
تملكها أو تديرها شركة إسرائيلية، ردا على الحرب الإسرائيلية على غزة.
ونحن نتحدث عن
جالاكسي ليدر الذي كان يحلق تحت علم جزر
البهاما وكان متجهًا إلى الهند من
تركيا. ويصر المسؤولون الإسرائيليون على أن
جالاكسي ليدر ليس مملوكًا لإسرائيليين
وأنه لم يكن هناك إسرائيليون بين
الطاقم في بيان وصف فيه الجيش الإسرائيلي عملية
الاستيلاء.  كحادثة خطيرة للغاية
ذات عواقب عالمية،
أكد متحدث باسم الحوثيين في وقت لاحق أن قواتهم استولت على
السفينة التي وصفها بأنها إسرائيلية،
وقال إن الطاقم يعاملون
وفقًا للقيم الإسلامية وحذر من
أن أي سفينة إسرائيلية ستكون
هدفًا مشروعًا.  بالنسبة لقوات الحوثيين، فإن
الحوثيين إلى جانب حزب الله ولبنان وسوريا
والميليشيات المختلفة في العراق هم
جزء مما يعرف بمحور
المقاومة الذي تقوده إيران. منذ أن
بدأت الحرب بين إسرائيل وحماس،
أطلق الحوثيون بشكل متكرر صواريخ
باتجاه إسرائيل، وكلها كانت
تم اعتراضه